welcome back we all know the scale the
strat fundraiser been around for quite a
while
people running up 108 flights of stairs
raising money for the nevada chapter of
the american lung association
and a shout out to the strat for all
their years of support but things are
changing
because of the pandemic so it's going to
be at a different location this year and
it's coming up a week from saturday
march
6th joining us now to talk more about it
we have shannon proctor the executive
director of the nevada american lung
association hey shannon thanks for
getting up early with us this morning
thanks for having me mate good to see
you so we know the event has
scaled the strat and again shout out to
the strat for all their years of support
it's just too confined in there so
moving it to
the las vegas ballpark this year that's
right
uh nate and you know i want to give a
big shout out and a thank you to
our presenting sponsor for since this
event's inception
anthem blue cross blue shield nevada
when the american lung association
decided to move all of their fight for
air climbs
outdoors because of the pandemic anthem
really stepped in to help us find
a stadium where we can climb outside
safely and las vegas ballpark came on
as our host this year we love the strat
we hope to return but we're looking
forward to a stadium climb this year
so folks kind of scratch their heads a
little bit shannon they go steps
at the ballpark yeah obviously they have
some i'm guessing you guys have counted
the number of stairs
out at the ballpark we have we have and
this year um it's gonna be a little bit
different if you've scaled the strat
we're gonna be up going up
and down stairs um so we're gonna kind
of snake through the lower bowl
of the las vegas ballpark and for those
who like to count nate yeah it's about
650 stairs
okay so we know that the climb is your
organization's biggest fundraising event
where does the money go that you raise
from these things
nate our mission is to fight lung
disease so we do that by
you know programming and services here
in in the valley uh making sure that
um we're funding research and and nate
we're currently the american lung
association funding our covet 19 action
initiative
this is a 25 million dollar investment
um to address covet
and to protect all of us from future
respiratory pandemics
so we're saving lives and we're fighting
for lung health
and the thing is about registering for
the event boy i looked at the website
there's already people raising a ton of
money
how do you register either in person or
virtually
well this year we are not taking um
in-person registrations because of covet
and safety we want everyone to
pre-register
online so to you go to
fightforairclimb.org
las vegas and register there's a 35
registration fee and we do have a 100
mandatory fundraising minimum really
easy to reach once you register
but we'd love to have you all come out
so register um we're taking
registrations until march
4th at about noon okay so we still have
a week or so to go and
channel eight in the past has had teams
brian loftus and
one of our assignment desk guys jonathan
sasowski
we've talked about getting together for
climbing this year i definitely want to
be there because
what an experience and what a way to
raise money shannon
oh nate we would love to have you guys
come out and take tackle the stairs at
the las vegas ballpark with us it would
be amazing to have you
we look forward to seeing you guys and
the other thing is shannon
while we do have the official name of
the event as climb for
air you can still get there when you do
scale the stride it'll still get you
there
good to know yeah okay so shannon real
quick before we go
i have done scale the strap myself for a
few years and we have a photograph of
what it's like
once you finish now most people are in
jogging outfits or sweatpants
i have on purpose just worn a flannel
jacket and work pants because
i want to show folks shannon that it's
possible for any person
to do this event and we're not really
timing ourselves
it's basically a fundraiser to help the
american lung association in nevada
right
that's right they i mean you do it in
style that's for sure
um we do you know give you your
finishing time if you are interested in
knowing how well you did
but it's really about the cause and it's
really just coming out
and having a good time and raising money
you know to fight lung disease
awesome shannon thanks so much for
getting up early with us this morning we
will see you a week from saturday
and again you can go to our website for
details or do scale the strat or climb
for air
shannon thanks again you guys have a
great day out there thanks nate i hope
to see you on march 6.
all right wow i love it that it's
the ballpark so nate we you're saying
that when we're climbing the stairs we
can stop by pick up a hot dog and a beer
well i don't know if the concession
stands are going to be open on a
saturday morning at the ballpark but
you can call your friend don logan
at the ballpark and see if maybe they'll
set something up for you one ringy
dinghy hello dog
special delivery